sometimes you just can't stick the
landing so this is a kind of a side
project I have been thinking about doing
for years and it's got to become another
occasional series a bit like why it's
awesome and nitpick rants just something
that I do every now and then so these
are going to be breakdowns of movies
that I think either were great up until
the very end or could have been great if
not for the ending and we're gonna start
with the movie that I saw that initially
kicked off me wanting to do something
like this in the first place and that is
cabin in the woods
now I shouldn't have to tell you that
there's gonna be spoilers involved since
this entire premise is about talking
about the ending I need to be real
specific about the point at which the
ending loses me and in this case I'm
also going to address the arguments that
I've seen in defense of the ending
because Trust may have hurt him and I
also don't agree with them but we'll get
there so cabin in the woods gets really
good as it goes along initially as its
as it's starting it's it's basically
cutting back to the control room that's
the best stuff and the stuff of the
teenagers is okay but teen teenagers in
been massive quotes and yeah that's all
okay but it's it's fairly generic but
again that's kind of the point but then
we they get down into the facility we
see all these other monsters then the
monsters get Unleashed and they just
start tearing apart everything and it's
gory and it's great a guy gets impaled
by a unicorn and it's amazing and then
we get the explanation of what it is
that's going on and why and we get that
from Sigourney Weaver and it works i buy
that explanation I get it
I dig it it's good the point at which
this movie loses me these teenagers
decide that they're not gonna go through
with it and that the world they're gonna
let the entire world end and I am NOT
okay with that I don't at this point I
don't know if the if the film wants us
to be on their side with the choice that
they make or not I'm inclined to say
that it is look I'll be flat out I get
iffy on nihilism in the first place
that's why I can't stand lars von trier
but in this specific case it really
infuriates me and I will explain why
first let me deal with the defense of
this move and the fact that effectively
we the world gets destroyed we don't see
the entirety of it but that's what's
going to happen the world will now end
because these two teenagers decided no
we don't want to do that so I understand
the metaphor I understand that the gods
that they are placating with by putting
on these shows and these tropes are the
audience I get the metaphor I get that
the gods are the audience who's they
expect things to happen in a certain way
and if it doesn't they throw a hissy fit
I get it it makes total sense and it
does not require the world actually
being destroyed to work that metaphor
works when it gets explained basically
by Sigourney Weaver having them actually
destroy the world doesn't enhance the
metaphor doesn't make the point stronger
it's just fortuitous and it wouldn't
bother me that much except that they
established just a little too much about
the world beyond this facility and these
kids and specifically they establish
children because we see the footage from
Japan with these schoolgirls fighting
this ghost thing and that if they hadn't
shown that I might have been
then maybe not loving this but I
wouldn't hate it because the reason that
I hate it is by including that scene you
establish the size and scope of this
world you establish firmly that this
world includes children children who
will now die because two teenagers had a
nihilistic moment and I'm not okay with
that the whole thing just over plays his
hand with this move and I don't I also
don't buy the argument of well if the
world requires these kinds of sacrifices
to keep moving well that's not a worth a
world worth saving that is an argument
that only works if at least the majority
of the population is aware of and is
complicit in what is going on that's not
the case here the population at large
doesn't know these children don't know
but now they're going to die they're
going to all die horrible terrible
painful deaths and it's not so much that
in and of itself but it's the fact that
it's set off by these two kids having a
nihilistic teenage rebellion moment it's
not even like it's a choice they make
out of fear because they don't want to
die
it's a measured choice they're gonna
kill the world they're gonna kill the
children of the world that we know exist
because we've seen them the films show
them to us no not then if you want a
comparison I don't have an inherent
automatic problem with world ending
stories you want to know a movie where
the world ends and it works dr.
Strangelove but there's a really big key
difference the reason that film works
and the reason that the world ending is
not only okay but funny is because the
world we are shown is very restricted
the only people we see are the military
and political figures who
part of the machine and caused the
entire friggin problem so as much as
they say in that film the world will end
the world as shown to us by the film
only capsule eights these idiots and we
can laugh at the fact that they're
probably all gonna die it's just a bunch
of morons because again just saying the
world's gonna add that's abstract what
solidifies what the world is to us as
far as the film is concerned depends on
what is shown and dr. Strangelove
doesn't show us children communities
schools a life worth preserving they
don't show us any of that they just show
us these idiot Airy idiots which makes
it fine that they're all gonna die
because that is this world as we
understand it as an audience but cabin
in the woods again showed us children so
you establish that this world is bigger
you establish firmly confirm show to my
eyes that this world is not just these
sacrificial teenagers and this idiotic
monitoring thing no is the world we know
it's kids kids will now die and I don't
care if you call me just a party pooper
I will come back to what I said before
it's not necessary
in order for the metaphor to work it's
just gratuitous it's just nihilistic and
I hate it so that is why I feel that the
ending to Cabin in the Woods doesn't
work it couldn't stick the landing those
are my thoughts what are yours do you
have a defense for this film that isn't
one of the ones that I have addressed as
to why I don't accept do you agree with
me you can certainly disagree with me a
lot of people seem to just if you're
gonna do that do it politely if you
don't mind but in any case what are your
thoughts on all this whatever they are
drop something down in the comments
let's talk about it all the stuff you
know the stuff like subscribe page
around support maybe I got shirts for
sale Twitter podcast
links for all that stuff is down in the
description and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]